- Thank you. Thank you
everybody for your patience.
It really gives me extraordinary
pleasure to welcome you all
here tonight.
This is the first real
day of the 2022- 2023
Academic year at the Yale
School of Architecture.
Also gives me great pleasure
to welcome you to the
Yale University Art
Gallery, which is Yale's
spectacular art museum, If
you don't know it already.
Our lectures typically occur
in Hastings Hall in the
basement of the School
of Architecture's home,
Paul Rudolph Hall across the street.
However, given the interest
in tonight's speaker,
we needed a bigger space and
our colleagues at the art
gallery have generously shared
their auditorium with us.
The pandemic rules in place here,
which I'm happy to see you
all observing is that everyone
must be masked and capacity
in the room is limited to 75%.
We do have an overflow room
at the School of Architecture.
So there nobody's missing this lecture.
Tonight's speaker is the renowned
architect, Francis Kéré .
Based in Berlin, Francis
is this semester's
Louis I. Kahn Visiting
Professor in Architecture.
So it's even more suitable
that we're in this building.
The Kahn Visiting Professorship
Endowment was established in
1980 through a series of gifts
from architects in honor of
the great Louis Kahn, who
taught a architecture at Yale
between 1947 and 1957.
You sit in a building designed by Kahn,
which opened in 1953, and
we are across the street
from another, the Yale
Center for British Art,
completed posthumously in 1977.
Former Kahn visiting professors
include Frank Gehry,
Peter Eisenman, who is with us tonight,
Todd Williams and Billy Chen,
who are also with us tonight,
Tom Phifer , Francine
Hoen and Lena Ghotmeh.
Francis, I cannot tell
you how delighted we are.
One that you have returned to Yale,
to your family here in New
Haven and the United States,
and that you are joining
us this year at the
as the Louis I. Kahn visiting
professor of architecture.
I'm not gonna bury the lead
any further. As you all know,
Francis Kere was the
winner of the 2022 Pritzker
Architecture Prize, the
45th Pritzker Laureate
he is also the first person
from Africa to be so honored.
Born in Burkina Faso, Kere's
practice is based in Berlin.
And in addition to the Pritzker,
he has received among many,
many other awards, the
Global Holcim Award and the
Arnold Burnham Memorial
Prize in Architecture,
from the American Academy
of Arts and Letters.
He's an honorary fellow of
the American Institute of
Architects, the Royal Institute
of Architects in Canada,
and is a chartered member of
the Royal Institute of British
Architects.
His biography is better known
thanks to the attention his
work has received since being
recognized by the Pritzker.
So I will not repeat it.
I think we're all interested
in hearing from Francis and
probably not so much from
me, but let me just say that.
In addition to being a
profoundly gifted architect,
he is an extraordinary
and gracious human being.
In these times, I believe
where arrogance often follows
achievement and it's
accompanying attention,
Francis remains curious
and interested, generous,
and caring, and continues through
architecture and buildings
to contribute to the
betterment of the world.
Please join me in welcoming Francis Kere.
(audience applauding, whistling)
- Hello. Hello.
I'm very happy that I have been
told many time that I'm with
my family, which is good for me.
I have to agree and confess
that time has become a very,
very, very rare and luxury,
luxury good in my life.
So I was hoping this lecture to be wow.
Then I found myself running
with the technology and then my
office is already shut
down. It is like six hours,
time difference.
However, Deborah, thank you so much.
This lecture today, I will
show you a lot of pictures.
My problem was because
I already spoke here,
cuz I don't want to bother people.
I was trying to show you the
new things I'm working on,
while hoping to have them.
Evan was traveling to shut,
take pictures of all of these project.
So I got them, but it
was not easy to put them
on my computer so that
why it took me so long.
I will kill you with a lot of pictures.
(laughter)
So I don't care. It's
not in the classroom.
I want to say that today
is a memorable day for me.
When I got an invitation,
I said, wow, I will come.
And that which should be my
very first lecture in the U.S.
since COVID.
And coming back to Yale is a great honor.
Not just simply because of the
happiness to be able to work
again with Martin.
Now coming back here, you know,
let be sincere as a Pritzker Laureate,
you really feel that I'm
still deep under emotions and
coming here, bring me choice
and gratitude
because allowed me to say
without really seeing my work
would have never been even discovered.
It is because of Billy that
I was awarded Archicad Award.
A philosopher told me this lady,
you know, do you know this lady?
I know, I don't know this
lady showing to, to Billy.
When I was standing
with my father in Delhi,
She fought for you like a
lion fighting for her babies.
(crowd laughing)
So in the corridors at the school,
you will heard Martin
and me fighting to say,
Billy is our mother.
(crowd laughing and applauding)
You have to sincerely
take this under account.
I was lucky and happy
that someone like her
was sitting in a jury
didn't know me and loved my work.
Today I'm here with a lot of
gratitude, Billy, you know,
your son has won the place card.
(audience applauding)
But I'm also full of
gratitude because you know it,
I came here because Deborah
got me here and my dream was to
connect, to have a network, you know,
to really also learn from this
school because I have a chair
teaching chair in Munich,
where I'm supposed to teach
in English while I was
hoping to teach in German
because this is the language that I can in
Europe, additional to French.
So I came full of,
you know, hope,
hope to just met.
But now
to realize
that she would be part of the jury for
Pritzker and then that's that my work
now has be being awarded.
Can you imagine how much
I was struggling to really come on
the stage and really
to be normal and speak.
I'm not a normal guy anymore.
(audience laughing)
No, this is pass.
Who, who who's that knows me
now that I will normally dance,
I will stamp. I will show
you how music in my culture
become part of my architecture.
How the women will work hard
and then to overcome the hard
work they will sing.
They will dance and
they will make a floor.
Now I'm considered to be serious.
I cannot do this anymore.
(audience laughing)
So, so let me just start.
Okay.
So, so to all our friends that
have joined us, thank you.
I try to enlight just a couple
later. I miss you, you guys,
so I'm very happy that you're here.
Now I have no fear anymore.
(audience chuckles)
So this work has, yeah,
this work just started
because I grew up in a place
and there was nothing.
There was no school. That why
I had to leave my parent very
early just to go abroad.
And I'm a privileged
person now, even more.
But at that time being
a student in Germany,
I was already feeling, I am privileged.
So I wanted to give something.
I don't like this word
of giving back. You know,
it has become very heavy,
but I just wanted to do
something for my people.
I wanted to create the school
so that the kids could stay
home and be able to attend education.
What brought me to Europe
until we started
very naive, very naive, to
really see what is available.
We have locally, I have
available materials.
You have people that are full
of enthusiasm and looking to
contribute. And so with that,
I just started to, to give.
And honestly, especially for
the student that what you see
here was built when I
was in your position,
I was a little older.
I started very late to study.
Many people don't know
that, but I was academically
on your age. And just, I was
able to do that and that what
Billy has awarded Pritzker, okay?
No, no techniques may not
work also because I'm nervous.
She said don't touch,
but I need your help.
However, just where is
so let me try again.
No.
So while she's coming to help and fix,
no I'm I just created this
school where there was no other
opportunities.
And then my people were so
excited that we were able to do
it. It was not, it was new, very modern,
but it was not like coming from
outside, because that is how
architecture has been seen is not,
I really need you to
come and bring it back.
Okay. So,
and architecture has been seeing
because modern architecture
that we talking, being
documented started because
with the colonial time,
they build huge things,
but no one could relate
to those buildings.
And so what I did was
modern, but for my people,
it was something at they reach, you know,
because there was part of it, honestly,
this is the beginning of my career.
I just want to go back.
And so it didn't took me very
long that people start to ask
for more of my project and
still, I didn't consider it to be
me, myself to be architect.
I was considering myself
as actionist.
And then you will be surprised
to see that I being traveling
a lot to do lectures. The truth is here.
I was not running
to show off or to show,
look at what I'm able to do.
It was simply because I needed the money.
(audience chuckling)
You know, if really, honestly, I, I,
I discover myself flowing
to the U.S. for 200, $2,000.
And then the flight was of course paid,
who will not come to the U.S.?
(audience laughing)
As a, yeah. A student. I
didn't have that privilege.
So I start to come and I
start to be everywhere,
fighting with swollen eyes.
But you know, I was
sharing what was moving me
to people and I was getting paid.
One more back and I will be brave.
Good.
Yeah. So how do you build
in that environment?
What I do, what I do is a lot of mockup,
Real one to one mockup.
And to really test because
I couldn't afford to have
professional joining us.
And so we build mockup and that
is so a picture that is into
me because I did it
running with the fiber,
hoping the structure that you
see will not collapse because
you want to prove your
people that you know,
better you're coming from a community.
No one has seeing you building, you know,
because to gain knowledge,
you're gonna run after your
grandfather or your father or
your grandmother for long
time and acquire knowledge and
end. They should be builder.
And when you come, you grow everyone.
We know you are a builder,
but Francis disappear from the community.
He went to a country called
Germany and he's spending so
much time. Instead of coming
back, we have nothing from him.
And he came back and say, hey
guys, I know how to build,
can you imagine that we'll believe you?
(audience laughing)
In the U.S., maybe.
So we had to do a lot of tests.
I hope it's gonna go.
I'm pressing, it's not going yeah.
With him. Yeah.
Yeah. So this is already the
extension of the, the school.
And from that moment,
I was sure I was able to build
and then I couldn't stop.
So I will be coming back to, to the west,
mainly in Europe first,
just try to raise money.
And I will go in schools in Germany,
talk to kids and convince
them that Africa is beautiful.
It's so great. But it's
missing opportunities.
You have a lot of little
kids your age having no
opportunities.
Honestly, this is how I raise money.
Not serious institution would
give you money because they
will say, why it's you
going to build a school
or not the government?
Cuz they don't know that
infrastructure is not the same,
like in the west. You know?
So I build it and every time,
so here,
when it came to color, the
entire village was part of it.
So I don't want to go through,
but it is about participation.
Really. When I was doing this,
I didn't have that vocabulary.
I was just doing it.
And nowaday, you know,
participation has become a key word
every time when I have
a new school project,
I'm changing the shape because
I hear it.
When people copy and paste,
dear student for detail please,
do me a favor. Don't copy somewhere,
a detail and put in your paper.
I will see it immediately.
I don't like it. You know?
So for my people, I wanted
to give different shape
of the building so that I,
that I can't keep, you know,
applying and improving what I
have brought and not to keep
replicating.
One, One thing that
is, that is stagnation.
This is to me, the problem in, in Africa,
You have a school model.
It's not even working well,
but I keep replicating it.
So yeah, many people start
to ask for project and here,
one of the very first client
is a surgeon
and he wanted
to create a clinic. He applied
to work with Meen frontier,
doctor without border.
And it didn't take him because
he didn't have enough time to
be there.
So he asked me if I can
help him create his clinic.
So of course, student, I
know how to draw sketch
just to show you the images.
And this is this picture
that I also have, thanks to Even.
What do you see is at the age
of the city at the border of
Ghana, but this project is our tech.
It is self-sufficient it produces
electricity, water, everything.
But if you see the kind of
solution that have been taking
inside this building out of
mud, you're gonna be surprised.
And that is what I'm able to do. You know?
So later on, so to think in my work, now,
if I start a project, I see
myself being ask to add, to add.
So actually I have like
eight projects that are not
finishing because the clients
keep asking to add because
there is a big request here,
you have doctor housing,
but already I have to double
the capacity of the clinic that you see.
Yeah. I'm using the
material that is available.
But I, I like things
that are very well done
or honestly this is so that
is nutrition for me.
Yeah.
And so the clinic is well
done is working well.
Really people get fixed.
Kids are there being happy
while their parent, you know,
getting fixed inside.
(audience laughs)
Who knows, who knows
the continent very well.
You know, a clinic, a
hospital is a place where,
where no one goes.
And basically the simple problem
is they will go when it's
too late. And so no one wants to go.
But if you go is place of dirt
and no one like to go there.
But if a city is kids playing
in a healthcare facilities,
it's so great to myself into,
I don't know how much time we have,
but if you go now to that clinic,
you will see hip hop from Ouagadougou..
the capital city of Burkina
Faso going to, to do videos.
And the first time when
I saw that, I say, wow.
Hey, what is here?
I want hear people to get fixed
and you come to do a song.
(audience laughing)
And later I say, wow, it's good.
People are looking for
structures. You know,
like to be like a, a frame for,
you know, for their own projection.
And that is how my project
are. And very quick,
all I'm taking inspiration from
the traditional housing for
the doctoral housing,
I'm giving them a is highest
hoping the patient will come or
their family and look
at and, and, and learn,
or let me use the word
copy in this case, I say,
copy the good product and bring it home.
So I'm making little models
that you could put together to
create a compare.
So it's collecting water.
It is biomass.
It's so really good.
And inside you have doctor
staying and myself. If I go,
I'm staying there.
If I'm lucky to go with
Martin, we may stay there.
Let hope. Yeah. And so no,
the work is basically what
you have seen. And
suddenly even in the west,
people became aware about
the work and asking me to
contribute to places.
Very quick here, the serpentine pavilion,
this was the first project that
has been giving visibility.
So the kind that people say,
oh, he can do also in the west.
So we did it sketches,
playing, looking the,
the fabric of
Kensington Garden, the gallery,
and then starting to do more
cap and create the structure
that will fit
until,
yeah.
It's almost like Gondo. I can't tell you,
you really design and think,
and then incompetent people
start to put things together,
layering like brick by
brick to create a facade.
And it looked like an UFO,
(audience laughing)
but it it's is done by people.
So this pavilion is now in Kuala Lumpur.
First
2019. When I was here,
there was a plan for me to
go for a big inauguration.
It has become a, a public library,
but then
COVID arrived,
postponing a lot of things,
but it's still,
still happy to yeah.
Remember how fine it is.
It is wood. Basically.
It is three elements, wood,
very thin metal structure
and
color.
Yeah.
Yes. About creating, gathering.
Always. If I have a job,
I'm thinking how people
will come together.
This is important to me.
It's about it.
And at the serpentine
time when I was proposing,
I know I want people to
sit and lean, and lean back
and touch the facade.
I think it was something
new that we did it. Yeah.
Yeah.
So I also went to the U.S..
That is a pavilion. I was,
had a chance to design for
Peter and Kathy Holstead.
It is a couple, I don't
know how to call them'
philanthropist? Artists themself?
But really open and very generous.
And the, so the first word,
when I met them, they said,
you know, Francis, you helping
build communities in Africa.
We want you to help us build
our community for Fish Day in
Montana. I say, wow, wow.
So someone, a couple comparing my work
with their own work in the U.S..
And I was like, wow.
It gives you such a
nutrition, a recognition.
You know that the work
you being see seeing as a,
a mother of heart has that recognition.
And we did it being
inspired by the Togona,
so he's here is a little drama.
This picture you see so nicely,
you cannot see it anymore.
It is at the border to Mali.
Nowadays you cannot go. In
the past I used to just take
a car with even ban will draw through and
just hang on and do things.
But you cannot because
it's invade by terrorism.
So I can go by myself alone.
Okay.
Potentially not now anymore.
After the media thing that came to me,
but normally I will go.
But if you have an European
looking person with you in the
age of cell phone, people
will call and say, hey,
in this car is money. Let kidnap them.
And you cannot go, is it tragedy?
So however,
getting inspired by those kind
of structure make sketches,
oh, Render's also student.
This is also part of what I'm doing.
But looking to the beautiful
forest in Montana and say, wow,
these is virtuous.
And then after I learned that
the native was using these
kind of wood to create
their housing, I say, wow,
let use it. And to create the pavilion.
And so like very simple material
that we use it,
Nina testing.
And that is a pavilion
that is still standing ,
In October I think that is
scheduled that I should go there
to do a movie. It's called
U.S by design.
There will be filming me in that.
So P many people will
discover this pavilion.
I really like it because it's
like part of the landscape,
but being wood and manmade
and in winter,
particularly it's melt
within the landscape.
So, okay.
But I have a lot of work to do in Burkina.
So people asking and here,
I show you very quick
or a aside started to
be like a high school.
That was the request.
That's a high school and we did it.
Now it has become a campus and
call even I might B I T you know,
maybe if I work, I will
call one day something.
Yeah. Because being
inspired by Yale for myself,
(audience laughing)
but here was about MIT.
And then we, we, we,
we just designed this always in my work,
I'm trying to increase
comfort inside the building
ventilation always.
And then to use like
a local material here.
This is like, right.
That we just cut, cutting it, give it up.
You know, for my people
is a sense of modernity,
but because it's regular, you know,
they know this material
they're being using it,
it fit well to the climate.
Wood is a big issue in Burkina Faso.
There is no wood, but
we have an alternative.
This can be a spacious.
And I wanna just use this
and then really create
the work something important.
What I do there is a job
engine,
really a job engine.
So when you can understand
that I have a workshop that is
bigger than 200, have more than 200 people
while I'm talking. I mean,
they're sleeping now, of course,
but normally have like three,
four construction sites going
on somewhere in Burkina.
And then I see the women sending wood
and they will earn money.
At the beginning, When I
succeeded in Gando, there was
adapt. It was his village.
It was his community. So as a young
architect, you have to prove,
you know, guys be ready.
So never give up if you did
it and you succeed somewhere,
they will say, oh, no, but don't give up.
So just keep going.
Here, we succeeded in places
that are 200 kilometer
far from Gando and creating a workshop
that is really working and to yeah.
Do a building like this.
So after this building, we
are asked to really design.
I'm rushing because I want to go to
the newest project that we have.
And you have seen potential
all of these images.
So some of these student
are now visiting, oh,
already graduated in the next
project that I had created
inside. So there is a big demand in this,
in, in Burkina Faso, but
in the entire continent,
it is keep growing.
And the fact is, it was,
I show the pictures before
I cannot go back. I don't
want the system to crash,
(audience chuckling)
but, but when we started,
there was no settlement,
really, that was at the age.
And now we surrounded,
I, I warned a client.
I told him, you know,
if we build this and it
is good and successful,
and he's working, you know,
land is going to be very expensive.
And that is exactly what is happening.
He, we cannot get more
land to extend the school.
And so here, because I'm traveling,
we develop modular
system, ventilation system
at class, I can show more.
But then what we wanted to do is to
really try another way
of building, not to really use bricks,
but to pour clay is not ram and earth
to pour it.
So I'm trying to check the
corner or the cracking,
how can I improve it with my team?
And then we go to production.
Here, the clan was generous
to help us with the farm work.
So with this, you could
pour one classroom.
And if you good enough,
you could just extend
it and pour a sort of
conference room.
And that is what happening now.
So it mean I can't just go.
And then my people just pouring
classrooms and conference
rooms, allowing the project
to grow, even without me.
So it's a lot of labor
that you see how it is,
so they will move it, keep moving it.
And it just growing
into to campus.
It's really,
yeah, best
suited in Burkina and
something that you may see.
There are trees coming up.
Furniture, I keep doing them by site,
on site because the site become
a production place for me.
And with the leftover, for the facade,
we creating benches that are
protecting the same time trees.
And it's always nice to see how
it's just shaping
very simple.
This is clay.
Comfortable courtyard,
wood, as a ceiling.
I don't have money for
this here, you know,
(audience laughing)
But I have alternative.
So a tower, which is
even better,
but I had no time to document.
Or even for the Prescott family,
I was asked to go and be
photographed in every single of my
building. But since I
had no time to go back,
but the tower looks so amazing
and kids has access to the
world because it is so high,
I change it.
The client wanted to put the
metal structure just for an
antenna and said, no,
let build the water tower and
the need of the water tower,
put administration for the
school and have a higher,
you know, structure to put the antenna.
Now student has connection
to the world, you know?
Yeah. And Hey, honestly, what
I'm doing is bringing light.
This work is like light
in places, you know,
that has no opportunities, really?
That is it.
So this is wrong is not coming soon
because it is already reality.
I like this project, it's a
slack campus in Turcana, Kenya.
I was asked to design a school so
a university and say,
okay, wow, good.
But this university is for people
that has no high school degree.
So meant to recruit young
refugees from Sudan, Ethiopia,
Somalia, but also volunteer from Kenya
and then give them a
computer and teach them
digital designing.
And they will be sitting somewhere
far from urban settlement
and earn money.
It was like a fiction.
So, you know, but sometime I like fictions
because I know who I am.
I came from very poor background
and I was able to do that.
So that idea looks like
you will laugh about it.
That what I tried to did at the beginning,
but I trusted him and
look at what we did first
I discovered Turcana's so huge and dry.
Okay.
And people will gather in
front of the termite hill.
I try to learn from termite hill
and then design the building.
So you will see the buildings
later are like this image.
That is what is happening inside.
And these student are
even trying to design.
They're not architect,
but they're designing.
They're doing a lot of stuff.
And then they're sitting really
there and being commissioned
even from the U.S..
And the first building
was opened And in during
end of just end of COVID
and COVID year number
two, it was already in full function.
And that is the building.
And this is the laptop they got.
What you need is energy
and a building that is,
that is not consuming a lot of energy.
And this is the result.
So I got that is pictures right now,
because even is like turning
there. And you see the, the,
the situation is really far from
yeah.
Every urban structure.
And what you see is the lake
is lake Turcana is water,
but you cannot drink is a, not salty.
Is it has a yeah.
Like salt water.
Yeah.
And the landscape is so fragile.
Now it's about building
housing for 300 kids.
So the project has been accepted
and so many student will
stay there. And so we designing,
working to build them yeah.
Creating yeah. Corners.
And then he tried to make light at night,
but the client also loved
this light. He says, you know,
Francis, we're bringing hope.
And again, I bring you back
to the notion of light.
You know, we're bringing light to places
where there is no hope.
If you to try to understand me,
you see that for most young people,
an opportunity is to go to
the next big urban city.
If you go to Nairobi,
Nairobi is so crowded a lot of problems.
And then you must be really
good connected to have a great
place there, but now they can stay
in Turcana and access education.
Yeah.
So, so career started with little things.
And then with the time people really look
at to what I are been doing.
And so here, an idea, I should
build a parliament house.
Okay.
So have being asked to do
many, many things in my career.
Really.
I always will really start,
start to study and check the
sincerity of the project.
And I will just enroll.
Here.
trying to imagine a gathering
space and also to learn from the nature,
but to go back in African
trad- West African tradition,
where people just gather together
under a big tree and solve
problems is real democracy.
If you sitting in the shadow
of the tree, you cannot sit
Or like we sitting, you know,
you're gonna sit around.
So everyone is equals, you know,
and while sitting, because
there is no a boundary
people will see you talking,
people will come and sit.
So it's really open. You will be talking,
taking a decision about the
community and your kids will
standing and listening to
you or your, your partner,
you know? And then you got, you know,
that you have to behave because
that is really transparent.
And I wanted to learn from that.
And this is called AGA pallab.
Palabra Tree if you may translate.
And I wanted to learn from
that and just design a project,
I design it.
And it's
by now
my biggest project,
it is now under construction.
So it's really a big,
now I can say
the idea
of the Palabra Tree has been chosen,
but I think that the client
didn't really understood the
complexity of the project.
And it made me suffer last year.
But I don't talk about suffering.
I'm talking about growing,
you know,
(audience laughing)
because this is most of you here.
Some of the teachers
being going over years,
like working on big, big project.
And so I saw myself facing
this, but in this project,
I was not just the architect.
Can you imagine I was in
charge of everything in French
It's called Mission Complex.
And I told, I put it like a
big character to my office.
If ever something like
this entered this office,
you have to say, no, really no.
Yeah. Mission complex means
you have to be in charge of
everything. This, everything,
everything talking to you
now, I just happened
to change the contract.
And now the government is taking
all these other, you know,
staff and I'm now in
charge of the architecture.
Oh!
(audience laughing)
I can't tell you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's construction. As I told
you, I couldn't put the images.
That is, it is like giant.
Like we, the dream was
to create the bigger tree
inside a botanical garden.
And it's coming short.
I think in less than two
years, we're gonna be so far.
The funny thing, when we
went to start construction,
there was a meeting and
I was called, Hey, Mr.
Architect, we want to
add a, a mil, a cazier,
like for soldier for 200
soldiers inside the site.
Room for 200 soldier,
the project was finished.
You have to go again and work
and work and work. BA my gosh.
Yeah. Okay.
Funny thing. Let's go.
But I'm still dealing on scale
project like this one for Dr.
Awuna in Kenya, Kogelo.
Aha becomes serious.
But in, in normal time, I will tell you,
if you look at two days, you
know, the people in, Kogelo
say people will come to Kenya
to check the house of the
Obama, but because this is a village,
but now people come to check
a house that is flying.
And for me, it's like an honor.
You understand? You know,
so it's showing what the power
of our profession, you know,
this project is so far good
because I collaborated with
people. I couldn't be on site.
It's like WhatsApp.
It's about correspondence
and talking back on forward.
But we, we, we made it.
And again, I got these pictures
from Even is always about,
Hey, honestly, to make
people happy, really,
to create an environment that
is positive for teaching,
for celebrating and doing whatever.
Yeah.
So here we just arrange the
volume the way that is just core
of, while you have a big
gathering, it is open,
but then you have like the sort
of semi-public private where
people can gather in
little groups, it's really,
really small and rich.
Yeah.
And I, from outside also,
you have like a way where you
could just gather and from
outside, people will be
watching and checking
what is inside.
And so here,
the project that I will
show you before ending,
I couldn't find a picture before,
cuz it was time was short.
But what you see is a
playground in Kampala, Uganda.
It's in an formal settlement,
there was no space.
There was just this space that
people showed to us with a
lot of conflicts because of encroachment.
And I've been working for five
years in this project back
and forward, really
trying to negotiate space.
Some of the people took the
space of the public space,
which belonged to a church,
a KCC
and many other organization.
And we had to really
negotiate with the neighbor.
People will be playing ball.
They will be playing track,
whatever, a lot of games
and boxing and body building
studio in this little, little space.
And the problem by playing
ball is the ball flare in the
neighboring plot. The neighbor is good.
Take the ball and threw again.
And he's happy another
neighbor, the ball will fell.
He take a knife, cut it.
(audience laughing)
So a lot of conflict, a lot of conflict.
And then with being, dealing,
going back and forward,
back and forward and to do it.
And that is how you see it,
how it full packed. Yeah.
And I really
thanks, Even for these pictures,
we happen to really create a
multi- functional structure.
So here we wanted to create
many, many form of gathering,
even little cozy place
for people to be happy.
Look at these faces. Can you see?
You know, also these faces
and, and this is all about
this project.
Even was catered to stay one
day, he end up staying three,
four days because I know his
schedule is so full packed,
but this little place
is so
used
that you cannot imagine
Myself, I haven't had the
chance to go, but it's like,
you know, this is what
you hope you create it.
And people take ownership
using every corner, really.
You see the existing and the new one,
even in term of colors,
we was able to adapt.
But
you, you,
I was told by my people
that the floor was so flat,
the kids has a new game.
They call it sliding. They just run and
(whooshing)
in the, in the floor and
it was, it's incredible.
You know, it's incredible.
And so we brought a water tower
because water can be sold,
can be sold there
or used to wash bottle water.
And at night you have
many kind of place.
Normally at night is
dangerous. You don't go there.
And yeah, it is, it has
become the most visited
site in Kampala.
Can you imagine in an informal
settlement and now it's a
little conflict. We have like
a storage and they say, no,
we shouldn't make it out of it.
People are sometime exaggerated.
We make exclusive coffee that
people that are wealthy should
come. And, and, and so then the question
what to do with the bottled water?
So, but that is so amazing.
So someone ask today,
what is the community part
of pro project?
If you work in this area,
it is you have to deal
and negotiate, you know?
So, and you could see roads
have light during night,
but so you have like little, little
light
inside the compounds,
but now you have light
for the community.
Yeah.
And I love water towers.
I love to build them. I've
been, traveling across Africa,
documenting water towers.
And I, I don't know if
I can use the word hate,
but they're so nightmare.
So ugly. So,
and I have decided to do
water towers differently.
And this is like the thing you did it.
We draw, it's like rivers really.
I, I,
I tested many times in Burkina,
and we just send the drawing and
Johnathan was able to
really make it happen.
He, he coordinated everything.
Yeah.
In the heart of informal settlement.
Playing, watching, being part of it.
So thank you very much for your patience.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
Thank You.
- Francis told me earlier that
he would be happy to answer a
few questions before we go
back over to the school of
architecture.
Let me ask that if you have a question,
you stand and you can take your mask off.
Are there microphones?
- [Man In Audience] Yes.
- Back there.
Okay. Thank you.
If you have a question, please
walk to the back cross aisle,
stand in front of the microphone.
Take your mask off and ask your question.
So everybody hear you and
we'll, we'll do a few.
- Just,head on back.
- Sport run, run, run.
(audience laughing)
- [Questioner 1] Hey, awesome.
So I was just,
my question is about the
form of your buildings.
How do you think about the
shape of the building so that
it's, it's regular, it's, it's detailed,
but it's not oppressive and
people are still feel like it's
friendly?
- Yeah, it's be okay.
It's first about, I mean, I
don't think about the shape,
but I'm thinking about
how I can protect first,
the building itself with the
roof, you know, so against sun,
you know, but also to create a shadow
and the rest is like putting
things together and get
it done. And so, and I,
I really like things that are
accurately done and inspire
and you know, and inspiring to people.
So the place where I grew
was honestly speaking,
not a place that can inspire young people.
And that is the primary
reason why I started to do
architecture. And so in
everything where I'm,
what I'm I'm doing is just to
make sure that everything fit,
thinking about the
economy, but to protect,
but to provide space where you
could just even use outside
the building.
You know, this is simply
the thing that I'm doing.
- [Questioner 1] Cool. Thanks.
- Thanks.
- [Questioner 2] Thank
you for your presentation.
- Are you, are you studying here?
- Yeah.
Okay, good.
(audience laughing)
You will do better roofs.
- [Questioner2] I think my question
has to do with the materials,
like in the variety of the
project that you have showed us,
there was a certain focus
on using local materials,
perhaps because of the,
because of the,
the brief or the standards
or the context or the
availability of these
materials in there. But I,
I just wanted to ask, like,
if there was ever any room to
go into these local context
and use different materials
entirely, and how receptive,
what would the people be?
And I'm asking this
because there's always,
there's often this fear
of marginalization of like
marginalizing people with
30 materials of context.
So what would happen if we
bring in like a different
material and what is the
possibility of doing that?
- So
what kind of different material.
- [Questioner 2] Something that is not
present in the context, for example,
in Africa, something that
is not clay, maybe concrete,
maybe any other material
that would seem fit for the
project.
- Yeah. So basically, I
mean, one day I just said,
I am a material opportunist.
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
Not a materialist, no like good stuff.
(audience laughing)
But I want to say, no, I want to say,
if I go to a place I'm looking
it's, it's very simply,
and it's it's for me.
The, the, the easier thing to do look
at what is the most available?
How can I use these in a smart way?
Don't say that I'm smart,
but I hope I am, but I'm,
I'm talking to apply the, you know,
the rules of architecture and
come out with something that
really work. It's about design.
It's about structure. It's about
security,
but also
some comfort.
And those things are guiding me.
And I will use everything.
Even cement block.
If I have nothing else, then
that I will use, if I, I,
I will even say I will use sand then,
but I needed not a structure
to, to support the, the sand,
you know, sandbags for example.
But I think there is no limit.
It is up to you really to try.
And then I'm looking if
something is there I'm doing also
sort of resource,
I will try to see how can
I use these material in the
different way, but you achieve quality.
I will try. And then for many people,
in many places we
building it's about having
a precedence to create
something that I see say,
oh, wow, this work.
But if it's like really
well- done and inspiring,
then there is no limit.
Yeah.
I, I, I have no taboo regarding material.
[Questioner 2] Cool. Thank you.
I use also concrete. I mean,
it needs basement sometime.
Yeah.
Yeah. But she, she, she did like that.
She, she was happy.
[Audience Laughing]
- [Questioner 3] Hi, thank you
so much for the presentation.
But, so my question is
actually quite broad.
I'm just wondering since cuz Africa is
at this moment,
like the youngest has the
youngest population and the
fastest growing population as well.
So which means at like now
there are a lot of kids there,
but in like 20, 30 years,
they're kind of growing to working adult.
And then in like 50 something years
they'll become like elders.
So I'm wondering,
do you have any thoughts on how can
architecture response to
this like changing demand
from like a lot of educational
buildings to like working buildings,
to maybe like buildings
for the elders in Africa,
especially on kind of the
budget control and the material
use?
- Well, it's really broad.
- [Questioner 3] Yeah. Sorry about that.
- Yeah, no, I mean, it's, this is,
let's say we have a survey now
we know that is a big need,
but we also know population
is growing and then it's us to
adapt, you know?
And then the more people you
educate and then the more
example you're showing and then, you know,
make it accessible.
People will keep transforming
it. So in my case, I mean,
if I say those that are connected
to information knows what
it is. I mean,
in Burkina Faso have the feeling
that every second person
want to become architects,
you know, they know this word again.
Everyone want to do that.
I think that, you know,
you will have a lot of young
people being interested and
then being trained. And when
they become 30 or professional,
they will just care.
And so learning from what exists
to really keep growing and,
and care or create structure
that sweep every, every need,
even for elderly.
What are, if I'm thinking about the school
and whatever that is easy,
but then that is a structure
regarding the family.
So the compound year in
cities, you will be alone.
But if you come to the countryside,
people are really living in a family.
We would have to develop
years that sweep very well.
You know, you attempt
by the project in Leon,
I created
sort of house that you can just apply
you know, you could transform it.
And so this will allow those
kind of structure to really be
adapt to the number of
people, but also be spread.
You know, I think that is it.
I'm not quite sure if I
answer to your question,
but I think it's it's, that is a,
a question of evolution
and it will, it will work.
Yeah. It will work.
People are aware now, you know,
they have a Pritzker winner.
(audience laughing)
Yeah. And they can win the Pritzka.
No, I mean, it is important.
Yeah.
It's very important.
Yeah. So I have become
a very serious person.
Have to be careful.
Okay?
- [Questioner 3] Yeah.
You say it like this. Okay, good.
- [Questioner 4] Thank
you for the visual feast.
This is incredible.
I, I also had a question about
kind of materials and methods
because you're working in
so many different locales.
I would imagine there's a lot
of different kind of bases of
construction knowledge that
differ from each other.
And what I've noticed from
these images is that there's,
if not consistency, a lot
of attention paid to detail,
to things all the way from site grading.
When you have walkways made
out of the pavers. to the
the thickness of the mortar
that's laid between the brick,
when you're working in all
these different locales,
do you draw a lot more?
Do you talk a lot more?
What is it that you try to do to get the,
the methods to work for you in,
in so many different places?
- I, I think this is key also, you would,
you see that my work is transformative.
It also, the loca depend on the location.
If you work in a really
countryside where there is no
nothing else in the middle
of nature, you limit it,
you know, the, the action to the building,
and then you could plant trees.
So to come, if you work in
the urban area, so, you know,
you have to deal with a lot of
issues that will push you to
really find ways paving
the Camochia project is
Camochia is
what you call a wit a wet
area is like a subject of,
for flooding all the time.
And then it took us very long
time because we had a main
channel getting all of the
water out at this middle, in,
in our plot. So if you
start with all of these,
you start with ideas to
make things fix and show,
protect the entire, if like
you let one corner untreated,
and then it will be a weakness
that may destroy all these
stuff. But depending where I am,
or pavement can be made with
really rough material like
granite, I do it a lot in Gando
I couldn't,
I didn't want to show a lot of things,
but because for the moment
I'm trying to reduce the
visibility, not to show, show, show,
I'm building a huge high school.
And then if you see how it's working,
we using rocks to really create
landscape and plant trees,
because it's very dry know,
I'm, I'm adapting where I am.
If I'm working in Germany
is a different area.
I didn't wanted to show all
of these and to get those that
love me, be afraid that I'm
working too much, but I'm,
I'm happy really to do it. I'm checking.
It's also about availability,
you know, resources,
if you don't have a lot of resource
you limit it, you, you be,
you know, you will limit the,
you know, the pot, the
extension of the project,
the landscaping can be
rough, you know.
And that's very defined like in the city.
Yeah.
Okay. He made like that.
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
- [Questioner 5] Hello Francis.
My name's Ryan, me and my friends,
we drove three hours to come hear you.
And it was well worth it.
- [Francis] Good.
- [Questioner 5] My
question's pretty specific,
but I was also really
intrigued by the water tower.
And I saw how, like, the
water gathers at the top,
but like kind of the bracing mechanic,
the wiring frame between
like the top and bottom,
I couldn't really understand
how the water would transfer
down or like how the people would
receive, like,
I didn't see no kind pipe system or maybe.
- Yeah, there's a pipe.
There's a pipe.
Actually, what we found on site,
we found that someone was selling
water to the border border
driver to clean their border border.
So actually what I do,
if I come to a place and
I have a job like this,
I will really try to study
and try to fit to everything.
And so the idea with the water tower camp,
you have seen a sort of
concrete base, you know,
- [Questioner5] okay.
- It is like where you have a
tap, you could get the water.
And someone is selling is
a, and then we have solar
that is pumping the water.
We, we, we just secure everything.
And we collecting under, under pavement.
I was asked about, we collecting
all the water on the site,
you know, because water is contaminated
and we're storing all
the water and we will
depending on the use, you will pump it.
And then you got it.
- [Questioner5] Oh, Okay.
- It's a pipe.
- [Questioner 5] Okay.
- And solar is a, it, it's not expensive.
Yeah.
- [Questioner 5] Very
interesting. Thank you.
- You're welcome.
So let plan won, you know, let design won.
- [Questioner 6] Hello.
So I've got just one question.
I think, first of all,
it's amazing to have you here.
And it's amazing to hear about
all the work you're doing for
your people in Africa. But, you know,
I think a challenge with a lot
of architecture in developing
nations is that the long term
upkeep and maintenance of it.
And I I'm just wondering..
Long term, long term?
- [Questioner 6] Long term
maintenance and upkeep.
- Ah, yes.
[Questioner 6] So I'm just wondering,
how do you consider that
challenging or design? Like,
do you try to make something
that is easy to maintain?
- Yeah.
- [Questioner 6] Or do you try to make
something that's, you know,
maybe easy to fix up
with what's available?
- Yeah.
- This is key: Maintenance
is a big, big problem.
And then, so if you see
the project that why,
so the detailing is also so high
because I want to make them
first stable and durable,
and then to reduce
the amount of maintenance
and also to give ideas like
the parliament house I'm
going to the big one.
We was lucky that the government
working with us decided to
increase the budget.
I think even 5% of the budgets
was kept somewhere for,
to maintain the big building.
But in reality, maintenance
has always been a big,
big issue.
Public building are not
maintained is a big problem.
If you start to build in this place,
it's up to you to come with
solution that are not subject
easily subject to, you know, to, to,
to be destroyed and you have to fix them.
You, you are right, but that
is part of the way I'm working
and I'm checking how
can I really fix them?
And if it's in, in Burkina Faso,
I have like a big team that
is able to maintain and to fix
thing. And so next to being an architect,
I have developed the structure
that is caring for building.
I cannot say you what we are doing,
but we're doing everything.
Fixing electric installations,
water supply,
deep wells.
And so we are doing
this, but everyone here,
if you want to build it,
you have to make sure
the building is stable and
come out with less maintenance
because few people will care for it.
So especially if it's
government buildings.
- [Questioner 6] That's everywhere, right?
- Okay.
- Are you okay?
- [Questioner 6]] Thank You.
- You're welcome.
- [Deborah Berke] This
will be the last question.
- [Questioner 7] Thank you,
Francis for your lecture.
I want to ask you, if you
think there's a major lesson
from the way you create
something relatively simple,
but so powerful in areas that
doesn't have much else into
societies that are relatively abundant.
- The key look, creating something, huh?
- [Deborah Berke] In a society.
If you've learned from a
society that has very little,
what do you bring to a society
where there's abundance?
- Yeah.
Yeah. I think I, I, yeah,
I'm facing this question,
but because we're in the
family, we try to I'm.
I don't know. I'm I don't know.
I'm seeing myself. I am now
someone living in abundance.
I have a lot of great people, great mamas.
(audience laughing)
And you know, and you know,
it's one of the privilege.
So, but I think if I'm thinking back
to places where people just deal with this
the, the minimum,
what we...
There is two, two answers.
So we may say, I don't care.
Don't give a s**t, but I will not do that.
Cuz we say it's normal.
So I don't want them to learn
from those people. But I,
I think we all can be a little
bit more, modest, you know.
We all can save a little bit
more and then we can learn to
from how people live in
scarcity. We don't need to,
to be like an as ake as ake
aesthetic.
Huh?
Yeah. We don't need to be that.
We don't need to refuse a lot,
but I think we could learn
a little bit to really start to save.
Your question is so fundamental
because we are seeing
every government in the west
and then in the rest of the
other world where everyone is
struggling because of COVID,
you know, we saw that
we really need goods
that we cannot have.
And maybe we start to reduce
consumption to know that
resources are limited.
And so I think that is a message
that we can really look at.
You know, I think that we
cannot just keep consuming.
Like we do.
I don't want people to start to be poor,
like people in Burkina Faso, but you know,
we need to think about energy
and to see how other people
from in other culture
are behaving, you know,
can learn a little bit.
- [Questioner 7] Thank you.
- Are you you satisfied?
- [Questioner 7] Yes.
- Yeah. Okay.
You have to.
- Thank You
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank You
- I'm done. I made it.(laughing)
Yeah.
- There's a reception across
the street at the school of
architecture on the second
floor in our gallery.
You are welcome to join us at this time.
- I made it.
I made it. I...